simone de beauvoir et mortelle et est
âgé de 78 ans écrivain militante
féministe elle fut la compagne de sartre
pendant ses 50 ans les ministres des
affaires étrangères européens réunis à
la haye aux pays bas pour trouver une
réponse politique commune au terrorisme
et à la tension en méditerranée entre
les états unis et la libye
le nouveau ministre de l'éducation rené
monory définit sa politique mais il n'y
aura pas de grande réforme grosse
affaire financière autour des transferts
de footballeur avant la fin du
championnat de france
luis fernandez y rajoutera si
aujourd'hui lundi 14 avril 1986 marcel
carton
marcel fontaine les otages français
détenus au liban michel seurat jean paul
kauffmann et l'équipe d'antenne 2
philippe rochot georges en scène aurel
cornéa et jean louis normandin n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir simone de beauvoir est décédé
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital cochin à paris à
l'âge de 78 ans cette simple phrase
communiqué en fin d'après midi annonçait
la fin d'un itinéraire personnel engagé
6,22 beauvoir écrivain prix goncourt
pour les mandarins en 1954 mais surtout
militante du féminisme et auteur du
deuxième sexe il y a près de 40 ans elle
fut la compagne de jean paul sartre
depuis leur rencontre en 1929 jusqu'à la
mort de celui-ci il ya six ans jean
jacques dufour évoque la vie de simone
de beauvoir simone de beauvoir disparaît
six ans après celui qui fut son
compagnon pendant 51 ans jean paul
sartre sur ces images le couple en
voyage à prague
ensemble ils s'étaient engagés dans
toutes les luttes de la gauche elle
avait personnellement ouvert la voie au
féminisme avec son livre le deuxième
sexe elle n'était pas mariée
et pour cause puisque elle parlait dans
cet ouvrage du lien matrimonial comme
d'une obscène institutions bourgeoises
avec sartre elle avait évoqué son oeuvre
parce que vous êtes comme moi vous
l'avez à fait terminée pourrait écrire
encore mais en gros
notre vrai diable je suis bien d'accord
alors donc on peut penser quelque chose
dessus on n'est pas en train à faire
dedans on est dehors et les cliniques
alors qu'est ce que j'en pensais je
pense que j'ai réussi à peu près ce que
je voulais je ne veux pas dire que c'est
ce que tout écrivain veut
et vous avez vu d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'autres choses et d'autres j'ai fait ma
veulent autre chose mais moi ce que je
voulais essentiellement c'était donc
parler je m'appelle utiliser sa voiture
angers allez osons principe de bouche à
oreille parler de manière que les gens
s'identifient avec mes héros et héroïnes
ou tirent profit que ce que je leur
disais et là je pense que j'ai réussi
parce que le deuxième sexe un autre m'a
fallu énormément de lettres de femmes
qui s'y référer qu'il avait aidé et j'ai
même vu des psychiatres qui m'ont dit
s'en servir pour faire prendre
conscience à certains de leurs malades
certaines surtout parce que c'était
surtout le pied aux femmes bon donc là
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui
était assez réussi et dans mes autres
romans et dans ma vie est remplie aussi
est certainement beaucoup de femmes qui
sont plus ou moins identifiés à moi vous
recherchez en tout cas à penser une
certaine ligne de vie à partir de celle
qu avec aérienne castor comme la plaie
avec affection sarfu la philosophe
théoricienne de tout le mouvement
féministe elle fut aussi l'une des
égéries du saint germain des prés de
l'après guerre
celui de la trompinette de boris vian
des câbles où l'on se retrouvait pour
refaire le monde dans une ambiance de
fête
c'est précisément dans ce quartier que
cette militante de la libération des
femmes aimées écrit sur une petite table
du café les deux magots
d'ailleurs c'est avec un tableau de
l'élite intellectuelle de saint germain
entre la libération et la guerre froide
les mandarins qu'elle obtint le prix
goncourt en 1954
auteur d'une vingtaine d'ouvragés romans
essais théâtre simone de beauvoir
pensait avoir réussi à exprimer
l'essentiel de sa pensée je n'imagine
pas de m'attaquer à des ouvrages de très
longue haleine qui me demanderait sa
cousine on travaille surtout que je ne
pense pas que ça ajouterait beaucoup à
ce que j'ai dit je pense que j'ai dis
vraiment l'essentiel tout ce que j'avais
à dire
françois nourissier disait d'elle
éternel étudiante éternel révolte et
cherchant partout la misère cachée la
duperie la statistique sinistre la
rencontre enrichissante
madame de beauvoir peut nous agacer
parfois elle nous touche toujours tout
ce qu'elle avait à dire comme vient de
le rappeler jean jacques duffau par la
voix de simone de beauvoir elle avait
publié aux éditions gallimard
simone gallimard bonsoir merci de nous
apporter votre premier témoignage qui va
vous avez connu simone de beauvoir à
nouveau voir je n'étais pas de ses
intimes
je me sens presque intimidé le parler de
quelqu'un qui ne voyait pas tous les
jours de très loin le leap d'elle que
j'ai préféré c'est l'invité j'ai été
aussi très sensible aux mémoires d'une
jeune fille rangée et puis enfin je me
souviens de sa pièce de théâtre c'était
sa première pièce je pense que c'est
peut-être sa seule pièce qui nous avait
tous pas mal et lui offrant comme
c'était un moment donné où tous ceux qui
étaient manifestation de kinkole gorges
de l'aveyron contre les douleurs le psg
commence une comme difficile bourg de
gérer rencontrés dans ces fameux
cocktail gaz humain et elle me semble
est quelqu'un de très appliqués de très
réservé de très observatrice et
on peut revendre se souvenait enfin moi
je ne l'imaginais très bien qu'elle
avait été professeur parce qu'il restait
un côté de d'expliquer aux gens de
d'enseigner en même temps des goûters
comme l'écouté ses élèves elle a été
professeur au cours désir je crois
d'ailleurs qu'elle avait été élève dans
ce même dans ce même court et je veux
envoyer un peu enfin comme quelqu'un de
très bonnes volontés mais de très précis
méticuleux
elle reprenait sa quelquefois lui des
noms c'est pas tout à fait comme ça elle
était peut-être moins moins facile que
sartre est plus pas regardante mais
enfin plus loin - douce son engagement
féministe vous avez surpris vous
interprétiez comment le vivez avec des
personnes qu'il rencontrait ça alors moi
je n'ai pas du tout vu que je la
rencontrais chez gallimard elle venue
déjeuner chez gallimard et moi pas très
souvent d'ailleurs mais je n'ai pas bien
perçu cela moi je l' ai perçu à travers
ses livres et c'était évidemment très
intéressante mais de l'été sensibilisez
vous femmes non pleinement
pourquoi tellement parce que peut-être
je suis assez frondeuse et moi plus cher
ou quelquefois mieux les les gens qui
sont peut-être qu'ils sont un peu plus
frondeur et plus plus fantaisiste d'une
mèche de 13 auster oui mais certainement
qu'elle savait s'amuser mais elle avait
toujours une réserve assez grande et je
la vois comme quelqu'un de très appliqué
merci sylvain galy maire nous avons
remporté ce premier témoignage
les ministres des affaires étrangères
des 12 pays de la communauté européenne
sont réunis depuis ce matin à la réunion
d'urgence à la demande de l'italie et de
l'espagne notamment il s'agit de définir
une réponse politique commune au
terrorisme mais aussi et de façon plus
immédiate d'harmoniser les réactions à
la crise américano libyenne
en méditerranée la fermeture des
représentations libyenne en europe
étaient proposés mais n'a pas été retenu
à la haye pour antenne de commentaires
de notre envoyé spécial
edouard l'heure
le colonel kadhafi pointé du doigt par
les 12,7 après midi à l'ail c'est un pas
en avant de la communauté européenne il
faut se souvenir qu'après la dernière
réunion fin janvier après les attentats
de bienne et rome dont vous avez réussi
le tour de force de ne pas mentionner
dans la communiqué le nom de kadhafi
pas plus que celui de la ligue cela dit
on le fait encore avec prudence en
faisant allusion aux menaces de kadhafi
disant le sud de l'europe et non pas sur
son rôle dans le terrorisme
international act évident que en ce qui
concerne le terrorisme international et
bien la libye un certain nombre de
responsabilités mais n'est pas seul à en
avoir quelques mesures concrètes au
niveau européen certaines avaient déjà
été prises d'autres le seront mais
chaque pays restant maître chez soi et
donc la pression générale ici ce soir
reste que l'europe des 12 souhaite que
le contact avec kadhafi soient rétablis
pacifiquement ce qui laisse entendre que
washington devra se débrouiller seul
dans l'hypothèse d'une action militaire
visant la libye et devant leur viennent
me confirmer que l'ats s'est déclaré
opposé une intervention américaine
contre tripoli que les douze ont déclaré
inacceptable de leur communiquer les
menaces de la libye quant aux mesures ou
trois séries de mesures citées par
edwards lors je vous rappelle qu'il
s'agit surtout de la restriction de
liberté de mouvement du personnel libyen
dans les ambassades
on réduira également se percevait les
puits un peu plus de sévérité pour
l'attribution des visas réactions
prudentes donc des pays européens non
seulement à l'évocation d'une
intervention libyenne en libye mais
aussi pour toutes représailles
économiques la grande bretagne y est
hostile
estimant qu'elles n'auraient aucun effet
contre la libye et qu'elle pourrait même
nuire à ses propres intérêts cependant
madame thatcher encourager l'europe a
répliqué aux menaces du colonel kadhafi
sans approuver une intervention des
états unis notamment
à partir de ces bases anglaise londres
alain cances le gouvernement britannique
est d'autant plus inquiet devant la
crise actuelle que 5000 britanniques se
trouvent actuellement en libye et qu'il
est convaincu que ce sont les bases
américaines situées en territoire
britannique qui servirait en partie au
moins deux points de départ et de vent
action militaire contre la libye non
seulement en effet on ne sait pas si sûr
le ce type de plan juridique le
gouvernement américain est obligé de
demander la permission à la grande
bretagne pour utiliser ces bases comme
bon lui semble de plus les britanniques
ne peuvent oublier que les américains
les ont aidés au moment de la guerre des
princes
les américains se chargerait au besoin
si ce n'est déjà fait de le leur
rappeler
enfin on note depuis quelques jours une
activité accrue sur ses bases a depuis
été attribués les vrais un exercice
prévu de longue date le potentiel
militaire américain stationné en grande
bretagne est impressionnant entre autres
bombardier le sens qui volts à deux fois
la vitesse du son
dsr santé 11 les oiseaux noirs avions
espions les terres qui peuvent atteindre
30 mille mètres d'altitude sans compter
des très moderne qu'à ses dix avions
chargés du ravitaillement en vol le
gouvernement grec est indiqué qu'il
était également opposée à l'utilisation
des bases américaines en grèce pour le
lancement de raid militaire contre la
libye
à tripoli le gouvernement du colonel
kadhafi menace en retour de réprésailles
l' agence libyenne affirme que des
commandos celui-ci partout dans le monde
sont prêts à intervenir et l'on a appris
que au moins quatre religieux avaient
été arrêtés en libye sous l'accusation
d'espionnage pour la cia à paris
l'émissaire personnel du président
reagan le général walter ambassadeur des
etats-unis à l'onu était reçu hier soir
par le premier ministre jacques chirac
officiellement saisie d'un échange de
vues sur le terrorisme
aujourd'hui le général walter c'était
reçu à l'élysée par le président
mitterrand pas plus de commentaire à sa
sortie du palais de l'élysée l'émissaire
américain sera ce soir à rome dernière
étape de sa tournée européenne pour
sensibiliser les pays de la communauté
aux craintes américaines concernant la
libye
trois semaines après son entrée en
fonction au ministère de l'éducation
rené monory définissait ce matin les
maîtres mots de sa politique vérité
efficacité réalisme monsieur monory ne
veut pas de grande réforme tout en
soulignant qu'il y avait beaucoup de
choses à changer pour adapter
l'enseignement la vie moderne on est
monory a présenté une liste d'objectifs
qui feront l'objet de décisions
concrètes d'ici l'été
estelle gouzy en rappel quelques-uns
j'ai lu l'autre jour en arrivant
je ne serai pas l'homme de la réforme
tous crins tout va que je viens pas du
tout pour qu'il y ait demain dans
l'éducation la réforme noria une
succession de réformes et c'est pas des
réformes du tout pour remettre en cause
l'éducation nationale c'est pour adapter
l'éducation nationale aux défis nouveaux
dont il y aura une section de réformes
qui feront peut-être une grande réforme
il tissera d'ailleurs la paternité on
reviendra aussi bien au ministre délégué
aux deux secrétaires d'état à moi même
je ne cherche pas dans cette affaire a
tiré le beau rôle
je dis seulement que il y aura forcément
ici ou là la part des syndicats de la
part je dirais des habitudes ou des
traditions telles ou telles réactions
bas je suis prête à en supporter la
popularité mais je changerais des choses
objectif rappeler par monsieur monari au
cours de notre journal d'antenne de midi
interrogé par estelle bout si l'union
nationale interuniversitaire l'uni se
félicite de l'abrogation de la loi
savary sur l'enseignement supérieur mais
le comité national d'action laïque et le
syndicat national des instituteurs
estime que les mesures en faveur du
privé sont un coup bas porté aux
services publics
quant à la fédération l'éducation
nationale se contente de noter le style
je cite lénifiants et patelin de
monsieur monory qui semble bien décidée
à appliquer le programme udf rpr à
monsieur monory ce matin les questions
n'ont pas manqué concernant notamment
les rythmes scolaires peut être un
samedi et un dimanche complets de repos
et puis sur la carte scolaire c'est à
dire la liberté d'inscrire ses enfants
là où on veut plusieurs expériences ont
été menées en ce sens dernières années
en france mais elle était limitée ainsi
à dijon l'expérience était réservée à
l'entrée en sixième reportage estelle
voulzy gilles de blaye quand les portes
s'ouvrent les parents choisissent leur
collège à dijon 700 familles ont fait
jouer ce nouveau droit
elles ont préféré pour leurs enfants un
autre collège que celui prévu par la
carte scolaire pour les établissements
cette expérience nouvelle de la
concurrence est une petite révolution
certains sont délaissés d'autres
plébiscité même si la plupart
maintiennent leurs effectifs au collège
rameau c'est l'hémorragie 71 familles
sont parties
abasourdis par ce record le responsable
s'interroge
je peux effectivement amener les
enseignants à prendre conscience que il
y a une image de marque a développé et
donc à être beaucoup plus sensibles à
cette image de marque donc à faire en
sorte que le projet de l'établissement
s'enrichissent pour de meilleurs
résultats à l'image du collège est
mauvaise pourtant ces résultats ne
suffisent pas à l'expliquer mais en
l'absence d'informations précises
la rumeur tient lieu de référence au
collège de béton de la banlieue certains
habitants du quartier préfère feu du
centre ville
jugé plus rassurant plus attractif et
pour leurs enfants les enseignants sont
les premiers à utiliser ce nouveau droit
j'avais choisi un établissement réputé
est-ce que ça ça a joué dans votre choix
ça a joué je dirais que ça a joué
presque à tort parce que halal usage on
s'aperçoit que l'établissement étape
ressemble comme un frère aux autres il
n'est pas du tout aussi différent pour
ne pas y croire et on a choisi un
établissement comme partout simplement
parce que c'était un établissement qui
nous a plu quand on a débarqué à dijon
parce qu'on a trop vite c'était beau ça
ressemblait vraiment à un endroit où on
pouvait apprendre des choses marcelle
pardé c'est l'un des trois collèges très
demandés en plus des élèves du quartier
200 familles ont obtenu une place en
sixième
l'ancien lycée pour jeunes filles bien a
su maintenir sa réputation de qualité un
corps enseignant stable en majorité les
agrégés des options rares russe ou
allemand première langue
une vitrine alléchante qui attire les
parents il ya des lycées qui ont des
bons résultats il ya des essais qui
tu as moins bons sont des choses qui
finissent par se savoir mais aussi même
si on donne pas toujours les chiffres et
que les parents sont évidemment sensible
à ce genre de résultat et on a toujours
envie de la mettre dans les meilleures
conditions possibles dans le lycée qui
obtient les meilleurs résultats il y a
les établissements qui ont une
réputation bonne ou mauvaise mais il ya
aussi tous les autres
impossible de choisir sans véritable
information à dijon les responsables de
l'éducation reconnaissent maintenant la
nécessité d'une plus grande transparence
moi ce que je propose déjà ses de
publier des d'évaluer correctement par
des critères objectifs
annie partout le comportement les
collèges et de publier ses résultats ici
chacun semble avoir accepté les
nouvelles règles du jeu
mais il est vrai que la dimension
limitée de l'expérience a permis de
donner satisfaction aux familles sans
entraîner déséquilibre au lait tendre
sans heurt à l'ensemble du pays
le ministre de l'éducation devra trouver
la méthode
réponse dans deux mois à la place d'yvon
schotter au poste de vice président du
cnpf chargé de la commission sociale
c'est monsieur jean-claude achille qui
vient d'être désigné monsieur jean todt
h il était jusqu'à présent président de
l'union des industries chimiques
monsieur tard avait démissionné je le
rappelle de son poste le 17 mars dernier
le mouvement de baisse des taux
d'intérêt annoncée par le ministre
edouard balladur connaît une première
application avec la baisse d'un demi
point du taux de la banque de france les
consommateurs devrait en connaître les
conséquences dans les semaines à venir
et demain dans cette édition de 20h nous
recevons le ministre d'état me the
économie et des finances monsieur
edouard balladur demain entrée en
vigueur de la hausse des taxes sur les
produits pétroliers hausse décidée par
la loi de finances 86 par le précédent
gouvernement
en voici le détail avec jean marie
dubois
17 centimes c'est donc ce que vous
paierez en plus à partir de minuit pour
un litre de super responsable de cette
hausse les taxes
demain la fiscalité sur l'essence
atteindra ainsi un record historique
73,6 pour cent du prix exemple lorsque
vous prendrez un litre de super 478 la
moyenne nationale
dedans il y aura trois francs 50 hier
pour les taxes le super augmente mais le
reste aussi pour l'essence ordinaire
la hausse sera de 16 centimes il coûtera
donc en moyenne 4 franc 67 pour un litre
quant aux diéséliste ils ont plus de
chance seulement 8 centimes de hausse
pour le gasoil et 3 francs en moyenne
pour un litre mais attention ces
augmentations demain vous ne les verrez
pas obligatoirement dans nos stations
préférées
cela dépendra de la concurrence locale
dans telle ou telle station il est
possible que les hausses ne soit pas
aussi forte
à vous de juger
président de la corée du sud est en
visite officielle pour deux jours à
paris c'est la première visite d'un chef
d'état sud coréen en france monsieur
chun doo hwan veut essentiellement
accroître les relations économiques de
son pays avec l'europe
monsieur chun doo hwan s'est entretenu
avec le président mitterrand pendant
1h30 environ
ainsi qu'avec le premier ministre
jacques chirac il doit rencontrer mais
l'arrivée du président sud coréen à
paris est aussi l'occasion pour ce
dernier d'obtenir une sorte d'appui pour
son régime en fin d'après midi près du
trocadéro à paris le parti communiste
appelé à une manifestation
un millier de personnes se sont
rassemblées andré lajoinie maxime
gremetz est pratique car nice monaco
après une prestation contre la venue de
monsieur chun doo hwan le qualifiant
dictateur sanguinaire les rappelant les
conditions de sa prise du pouvoir en 79
la manifestation du pc avait été
interdite par la préfecture de police
le président chomdu un accéda
effectivement au pouvoir à l'issue de
plusieurs milliers d'arrestations de
condamnation et d'affrontements ayant
fait sans doute plusieurs centaines de
morts daniel leconte explique les
conditions de cette accession à la tête
de la corée du sud par monsieur chun doo
hwan le président chun doo hwan prête
serment
nous sommes le 3 mars 1982 pour la corée
du sud
c'est la fin d'une époque 1950 c'est la
guerre fratricide entre le sud et le
nord du pays jeune john est un soldat
comme un autre qui se base sur le fond
contre le communisme
la guerre finie l'obsession pour tous
dans ce pays de 40 millions d'habitants
c'est le péril rouge incarné par cette
frontière la ligne de démarcation
au delà c'est la corée du nord aligné
sur moscou pour combattre ce péril
quarante mille soldats américains en
permanence et un régime fort qui
s'appuie sur l'armée
c'est donc d'abord là dans l'armée que
le futur président va construire son
destin académie militaire commandement
d'un régime d'élite coréen pendant la
guerre du vietnam
et pour finir la direction des services
de renseignement c'est ce poste clé qui
va lui permettre d'arriver au pouvoir à
la faveur d'un coup d'état en 1979 au
départ john n'est pas différent des
autres dictateurs qui se sont succédé
avant lui
arrestations en masse pelouse lâche de
l'opposition licenciement des
fonctionnaires des journalistes ou des
enseignants puis peu à peu le régime
commence à pratiquer une politique
d'ouverture
encouragée par washington ouverture
économique d'abord une main d'oeuvre bon
marché docile 54 heures de travail
hebdomadaires en moyenne
résultat seoul devient le 13e
exportateur mondial
ouverture politique ensuite il lève la
loi martiale libère certains prisonniers
politiques et organiser des élections
législatives en février 85 qui seront
marquées par la victoire de l'opposition
ouverture diplomatique enfin il
rencontre et gagnent jean paul ii et
margaret thatcher autant de voyages au
cours desquelles le président john tente
de changer l'image de marque de son pays
c'est là d'ailleurs l'un des objectifs
de sa visite officielle en france reste
pour ses détracteurs deux obstacles
majeurs un chiffre mille prisonniers
politiques et une lacune de taille le
président chun a été élu par un collège
électoral
il réclame maintenant le suffrage
universel c'est justement ce que
l'opposition s'est chargé de lui
rappeler dans la rue avant son départ
pour l'europe selon le congrès juif
mondial un rapport secret signé de
kurzweil am a été utilisé en 1944 par
les procureurs américains au procès de
nuremberg ce rapport serait une
confirmation des crimes de guerre
imputés monsieur van damme qui a rejeté
à nouveau aujourd'hui les accusations
portées contre lui en afrique du sud la
police a annoncé que 14 noir avaient été
tués au cours d'émeutes ces deux
derniers jours à travers le pays à
pretoria le poète près dun breitenbach
français d'origine sud africaine que
l'on voit ici est violemment pris à
partie la minorité blanche qui se
maintient par la répression puisque
michael bolton bac effectue là sa
première visite en afrique du sud depuis
1982 il y fut détenu pendant sept ans
son recueil de poèmes écrits pendant sa
détention
sauveur décerner un prix près qu'il a
reçus à pretoria en france bernard stasi
député cds déclaré qu'il ne voterait
jamais une mesure aussi stupide que la
peine incompressible de 30 ans annoncé
par monsieur chirac
selon monsieur stasi c'est une mesure
qui n'existe nulle part ailleurs et qui
a été inventé pour satisfaire une
opinion mal informés aux assises de
paris au procès de lionel cardon dont le
verdict est attendu mercredi soir
c'était aujourd'hui les plaidoiries de
la partie civile
compte rendu paul le faire lors des
parties civiles des victimes n'est
jamais facile en assises pour un accusé
aujourd'hui le regarde de femme n'a pas
quitté lionel cardon la mer et la femme
du brigadier claude hochart a battu par
cardon dans le bois de boulogne et
surtout la voix rocailleuse de leurs
avocats henri rené gareau qu'est ce que
vous nous raconter avec votre tir
instinctif
nous gardons vous êtes un champion du
titre préventif
en réalité vous ne vouliez pas retourner
en prison vous avez viser et tirer deux
fois la vie de ce flic comme vous dites
pesé moins lourd que votre liberté
calonne ni fasciste crie alors cardon
qui une nouvelle fois explose
auparavant deux phrases d'avocats qui
résume bien les débats d'abord vous
noterez carélie pour annette cannes
dicter un papier un journaliste avec un
revolver c'est un droit de réponse
ensuite denise mialouh pour un policier
blessé
la légitime défense pour vous car dont
s'est tiré sur des policiers en se
protégeant bien sûr derrière une femme
cardon n'arrête pas de prendre des notes
il veut intervenir longuement à la fin
des débats demain réquisitoire verdict
mercredi soir l'homme d'affaires
israélien samuel flattot sharon qui
étaient arrêtés en italie au mois
d'octobre dernier puis remis en liberté
sous caution s'est enfui la france avait
demandé son extradition
sport football s'est fait luis fernandez
milieu de terrain de l'équipe de france
et capitaine du paris saint germain a
signé un contrat de trois ans au racing
club de france 2 jean luc lagardère
luis fernandez est âgé de 26 ans il n'a
pas confirmé les chiffres de dizaines de
millions de francs de son nouveau
salaire ce sera sans doute l'un des plus
gros transfert du football français de
cette saison mais le marché reste ouvert
en quête d'un vernon
luis fernandez c'est une star du
football français que les clubs
européens volts acquérir pour renforcer
leur jeu et gagner dans d'éventuelles
coupes d'europe fernandez le sait alors
un transfert se prépare de deux façons
première méthode convaincre sur le
terrain de sa valeur fernandez plaît
parce qu'il donne toute son énergie au
football et son palmarès vient en plus
de s'enrichir il est champion de france
avec paris saint-germain fernandez n'a
plus qu'à attendre la surenchère des
clubs l'ancien bambins des minguettes
vote aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines de
millions de francs veut aller trop loin
c'est un peu un manque de respect
vis-à-vis des gens que je dis toujours
qui qui ont un mal fou à faire vivre une
famille à élever des enfants car j'en
connais le le principe j'étais là dans
mon enfance et quand je travaille en
usine je voyais les gens le mal qu'ils
avaient pour go pour gagner de l'argent
alors je crois que quand on parle de ce
chiffre ça ça fait dépasser un peu le le
stade c'est pour ça qu'il faut savoir
rester quand même un peu plus en retrait
de pas donné de chiffres extravagants
en fait comme tous les internationaux
fernandez champion d'europe for it est
paradoxalement très pudique sur le
montant de son transfert aux racines la
deuxième méthode pour réussir à mon
transfert c'est celle de tigana il
écoute les sirènes et choisit finalement
la fidélité monnayer à bordeaux le futur
avant centre du paris saint-germain
jules bocandé n'a pas encore de palmarès
c'est donc ses qualités physiques sa
jeunesse sa technique qui séduisent les
clubs
c'est aussi le cas de philippe
vercruysse le lensois de ma bordelais
des jeunes qui vont doubler voire
tripler leur salaire
bon il ya beaucoup d'argent en jeu c'est
sûr mais le sport fait le football
surtout d'un attentat un spectacle
déplace les foules je dire pourquoi
transférer de l'argent l'argent que l'on
trouve à l'étranger la vedette
yougoslave vujovic a choisi bordeaux
tiens tiens tigana a sans doute fait le
bon choix pour la météo de demain on
retrouve laurent boucher puis et côté
météo ça vous jo ça n'est pas encore
l'été à peine à peine le printemps et
pourtant ça bouge nous ennuie comme
notre salut viennent de l'ouest regardez
la photo satellite avec une magnifique
dépression au large de l'irlande et 3
perturbations la première était sur la
france elle va s'éloigner vers l'est
la deuxième était sur l'angleterre est
sur l'irlande elle va venir demain sur
la france et la troisième est sur
l'atlantique nous l'attendons pour dans
48 heures alors évidemment il y a encore
il y aura encore des nuages demain donc
il ya des nuages sur la carte du temps
prévu avec des pyrénées au massif
central aux alpes à la région à la
franche comté à la région bourgogne
lorraine alsace un ciel très nuageux le
matin couvert avec quelques petites
pluies des orages éventuellement sur la
région provence côte d'azur et sur la
corse un ciel très nuageux qui
heureusement s'éloignera un petit peu
vers l'est dans la journée sur la moitié
ouest du pays un temps un petit peu plus
clair avec encore des nuages résiduels
il en faut à grands pas ils peuvent pas
tous partir d'un seul un seul coup et
puis quelques averses plus ou moins
importants que le tout poussé par des
vents d'ouest nord ouest modéré modérés
tout va mieux par contre où ça va mieux
c'est côté température regardez c'est
pas encore le printemps je vous le
disais mais on se rapproche le tapis des
normales saisonnières de 12 à 15 degrés
sur la moitié nord ça va nettement mieux
est de 15 mais jusqu'à 17 degrés sur la
moitié sud 17 degrés à biarritz et à
l'autre extrémité 17° à bastia voyez ça
va un petit peu mieux serait un petit
peu mieux le reste de l'europe puisque
demain il soir pour six avec 4 degrés
seulement à oslo mais déjà 21 degrés à
athènes demain ce sera le mardi 15 avril
le soleil se lèvera à 7h02 couchera
20h40 3 minutes de soleil en plus et
nous fêterons les patterns actualité de
ce lundi 14 avril je vous rappelle que
nous avons appris cet après midi le
décès de simone de beauvoir à l'hôpital
cochin paris simone de beauvoir était
âgé de 78 ans
dernier journal présenté par philippe
harrouard à 23 heures avec un débat
débat sur les radios libres et
l'audiovisuel annick cojean du monde et
franck eskenazi de libération seront les
deux invités de philippe harrouard à
6h45 demain télématin pij de vous
signaler c'est l'avis de ma 18h30 toute
une série encore toute cette semaine à
demain 20h bonsoir merci